that to me
is is one of the the nicest sounds that
that there can be
we leave it at that
right we're going to do sigma
mathematicians i guess might fear that
we're encroaching on their their
territory but let's just define what
what sigma means it means a summation so
for example if we wanted to write down
one plus two plus three plus four plus
five then what we'd have would be
something like this it connects into
very very many areas of physics
including quantum mechanics but what i
really to focus on is something called
fourier analysis this was a guy called
john baptiste fourier who developed an
entire theory with all those but largely
he put the key ideas and entire theory
of the analysis of waves quantum
mechanics fundamentally relies on an
understanding of the usage of waves but
that's not the only
area of course of physics we can think
of music we can think of sound
engineering we can think of
engineering problems all of these things
involve waves
the general picture of a wave is
something that looks like this so that's
a standard picture where something
that's very simple very regular moves
back and forth
in a very simple what we call this
mathematically a sinusoidal or
cosinusoidal pattern but you can take
any complicated wave and the beauty of
furry analysis is you can say well that
just comprises
a set
of simple sinusoidal and co-sinusoidal
or harmonic
components or harmonic
bits
let me just get a really really boring
wave up so
so what we have is probably what um you
can what most people will consider what
what sound waves look like a very simple
sound wave but the key thing is is that
down here we've got the wave and time
and down here we've got the wave and
frequency this is a a rubber wire which
i'm oscillating at a particular
frequency
so well this is an incredibly incredibly
poor um les paul copy that i got for 100
quid a while ago and you can see that
there is
a displacement at the end
in here as i stamp it down and it'll
build up again and no displacement there
or in the middle these are called the
nodes but the only time i used to play a
lot of guitar but the only time i get to
play guitar now is actually when i bring
it into lectures and this is a standing
wave on this string just like on a
guitar string
and i've irritated quite a few
generations of undergraduates bringing
in guitars and telling them about furry
analysis but now you can see that there
is a wave that comes up and goes down
and comes up and it's oscillating with
time
if i were to change
the frequency
it will go and disappear and then you'll
if i'm clever enough i'll get the next
harmonic up
and it will resonate
and this will have a higher frequency
but now i've got a node here and a node
here and of course at the ends
we'll have to turn things up a little
bit but what i want to get across first
of all
is this idea that
you think of waves or generally we think
of waves as that very simple signal we
saw um very simple sign wave and
and then you can have other modes that
will disappear
and this one will make a bit of a noise
don't worry it's not gonna
for the building in but that's the
frequency of this and there's a node a
node and no and we're going through and
building up different waves
so what you can see is instead of it
being a very simple
regular one component as we said one is
sinusoidal component you can see that
it's a it's a much more complex signal
so if we look at that on our spectrum
analyzer
then what we see is that that particular
guitar tone is not just made up of
the the one frequency it's made up of a
number of different frequencies and this
is key it's that it's that combination
of frequencies combination of harmonics
that allows us to distinguish an a note
on guitar
from an a note on piano or an a note on
a trumpet or an air note on a
whatever
so if i were to turn this off
and displace
the wave by plucking it at a certain
point
i can think of this as being the
fundamental which is the one that goes
up sinusoidally like that plus a little
bit of the next harmonic
plus a bit of the next harmonic when
it's going up and down like that
when you clear the string we have this
is the the ends one end of the guitar so
this is here this is the nut and here's
the bridge and so the fundamental mode
or the fundamental
frequency
looks like that
the next one and we get all these
different what are the terms standing
waves but you can see that they're nice
sine wave
components and what you do is you add
those up
and that and the mixture of those
and the the strengths of those
gives you the sound of the note and it's
the sum of all these different wave-like
motions
that makes up the guitar string as i
pluck it in a particular place and as i
pluck it in different places
you'll get a different shape
the key thing is that you're building up
these notes you're taking
many different ingredients making a mix
making a stew making a cake whatever you
where you want to call it but by mixing
those ingredients in different ways you
get different tones you get different
flavors the idea of furry analysis is to
build up
any shape like this however you pluck it
if you pluck it in two places or
whatever as a sum of these different
standing waves but the neatest way of
accentuating those frequencies and
playing around with those frequencies
is
to use something called a wire pedal and
this idea can be used throughout physics
if i were to make this thing longer and
longer and longer i would change the
frequencies and i get many more
frequencies coming out
this idea is due to mission fourier of
french mathematician if you make this
longer we call that a fourier transform
which is what professional physicists
use but first of all you have to learn
about the fourier series well let's just
focus on one note so when you play that
and if i keep the y pedal
fully up so i'm accentuating those low
notes
and then if i push it forward
you see that i'm now accentuating the
high notes and i've pulled down the low
notes at the expense of the high notes
and then when you sweep those two
and there will still be the ones up to
the point where you can't hear which in
your case is going to be much higher
frequencies than an old man like me
who's lost half his hearing at the high
frequency range it used to be an x-ray
machine in here and and it whizzed and
when i was 25 30 i could hear the
whizzing noise and the students can hear
it and it would drive you to distraction
when i got up to 40 i couldn't hear it
at all the students complained to me and
i could remember that it made this
horrible noise but you lose that higher
frequency range